(pleasant music)
- The artifacts speak louder than words,
the way that we've preserved them.
It's not what we said, it's what we did,
and they all speak very loudly
for generations and generations to come.
My name is Barry Clifford,
and I'm an explorer.
- [Narrator] Barry Clifford
has dedicated his life
to finding and preserving
shipwreck treasure.
- Head towards the east, Chris.
- [Chris] All right, stand by.
- [Narrator] His team is
responsible for discovering
the Whydah,
one of the largest pirate
shipwrecks in the world
valued at over 400 million dollars.
- The Whydah was a slave
ship captured by pirates
and it wrecked off of
Wellfleet, Massachusetts
in April of 1717.
I've been diving on it since 1982.
I bought a boat and spent
the next couple of years
looking for the ship.
And then in 1984, we
found the first artifacts.
And then we found the ship's bell.
And the ship's bell said,
"The Whydah Gally, 1716."
Everything is buried at least
15 to 30 feet under the sand.
So we have to dig a hole
sometimes 30 feet deep
to get down to artifact layer.
You know, you need precise
positioning equipment,
precise anchoring techniques,
and a way to dig very gently
so you don't destroy or
disturb the artifacts.
There's some big chunks
of gold here, Chris.
- [Chris] Wow, look at all the gold.
Oh, my God.
- I had no idea how much
stuff we would find.
When you're talking about
hundreds of thousands of artifacts,
you know, we have years
and years and years of work
to conserve everything
that we've brought up.
That's a spelt that might
have been used from a rum keg.
- [Narrator] Unlike your
typical treasure hunter,
Barry has never sold any of
the artifacts he's found,
choosing to put them on
display for the public to see.
- I made a promise to myself early on
that I was never gonna sell the treasure,
that we would keep it all together.
And my crew and my family
and people who've worked
with me over the years
have all felt the same
way about preserving this
for our cultural heritage.
Take your time, no rush.
I'd be lying if I said it wasn't fun.
You're not gonna believe
what that is, Chris.
I still get just as excited
about finding something
as I did 35 years ago.
(pleasant music)